- [Voiceover] It's Hamburg, Germany.
The year is 1669.
Inside of a basement laboratory,
alchemist Hennig Brand
is boiling gallons of urine
to create the fabled philosopher's stone.
Unbeknownst to him, the urine
is about to lead to a truly
world-altering discovery.
(inquisitive grumble)
(lively music)
During the middle ages,
the philosopher's stone
was the coveted discovery
because it was believed
it could turn ordinary metal to gold.
In his quest to find it, Brand accumulated
over 1,500 gallons of urine.
(chuckling)
He thought that by purifying the waste
the philosopher's stone would
materialize in what was left.
The process went like this.
One, age the urine until
an intense odor billows
out of the samples.
Two, boil the urine until
a white paste materializes.
Three, place the heated
paste in a retort.
Four, gold will then drip out of the—
(inquisitive grumble)
Wait what?
(chiming bell)
Okay, so it wasn't gold that emerged,
but a solid white substance
that glowed in the dark.
This was big, this was bigger than big.
His discovery was gonna change the world.
Brand had discovered phosphorus
one of the building blocks of life.
Making him the first person
to ever discover a chemical element,
but the thing was, he had no idea.
He believed he had found a
glowing philosopher's stone
and named the substance phosphorus,
meaning bringer of light.
Brand kept his discovery a secret
until he eventually sold his
process to other scientists.
It wasn't until after his death
that he was given credit
for discovering phosphorus.
All by boiling urine in
his basement laboratory.
(dramatic instrumental music)